he is none other than PJ Carlesimo how
are you coach
hey we're telling you really good thank
you yeah glad to have you on here man
happy to what what was the biggest
surprise for you that you personally I
bawled this past weekend personally I'd
have to say the only real surprise you
know in ours was Syracuse over Michigan
State but calling it a surprise is night
I mean I'll tell you you know as you
well know first of all Syracuse is a
very good team and that zone is the bear
for teams that haven't played against it
and it's kind of strange the Big Ten is
a man-to-man league and as great a
3-point shooting team as they are and as
good a rebounding team as they are I
mean at 29 offensive rebounds Michigan
State I'm not you know I can say
honestly I thought it was going to be a
good game if you made me pick of course
I would have picked Michigan State but I
can't say I'm really surprised but of
the six teams we had that was the only
one that people kind of were like wow
how did that happen but you know if you
know again these teams played in the
regular season you know that's the thing
everybody goes a little buggy with the
seeding numbers and everything in the
tournament if Syracuse plays Michigan
State in the regular season everybody
goes loose a nice matchup ACC Big Ten
who's gonna win this one they play now
and they put the numbers on them and
everybody goes how did whatever they
were at to lose to an 11 or whatever so
you know I kind of laughed sometimes
particularly when it's the big
conferences now you start talking UMBC
or some of the other ones that blew me
away I thought UVA was the best team in
the regular season in the country and by
a clear margin I mean they dominated
arguably the best league in the country
from day one till the end of the year so
if that game was a stunner beyond belief
well I mean and I know you're one of
those two I said this yesterday being a
Staten Islander growing up born in a
born in Brooklyn raised in Staten Island
it's tough to call Syracuse an ACC team
I will never get used to that thank you
and you you being a guy who was around
Wagner college for all those years I
know you are you know in all those years
at Seton Hall what makes it so tough
that two three zone what
so tell us about it when you first of
all it sounds simplistic but that's all
they play and most people that mess
around with zones it's their second or
third defense you know like I'm a
man-to-man team but I'm gonna put his
own in and they you know they don't do
it as well
Jim is Oh Jim only placed a 2-3 zone so
first of all he's he's the best teacher
in my opinion of the 2-3 zone ever you
can talk about how he lay back in the
Great Temple zones and all that stuff
but I mean I I think I could defend that
statement he's the best teacher of his
own there's ever been
that's all they play so that's a huge
thing they recruit to it they have this
incredible length they've got guys with
you know good hair and long arms good
aim and they recruit that way so they
play the zone very very well and other
people are not used to playing against
it now
that's out the window a little bit in
their next game because they're playing
Duke who plays them every year you know
so it's not as big a factor but they
play a michigan state or they play
somebody that hasn't seen a their zone
or in Michigan State's case not very
much sown at all it's night and day
difference Mike Hopkins came out to
University of Washington I live in
Seattle Ridge he came out to University
of Washington and did a great job he
went 20 some games I got beat last night
by st. Mary's in the NIT but again same
thing one defense it was kind of new to
the pac-12
people had trouble adjusting he beats
Kansas in Kansas City in the regular
season with it had an unbelievable
turnaround years coaching here in the
pac-12 should be and it makes for coach
of the year in the country but same deal
again one defense and as he recruits
players that fit that style he'll be
even more effective in the future PJ
Carlesimo here on the Rich Eisen show
before we turn to the pros I want to
spend a couple more minutes on the
bracket who do you think wins it now
that you can if you could redraw right
now redo your bracket from here on out
would it be any different well I I don't
mess with practice III always laugh and
say I'm not smart enough to figure it
out I watch a game and I can tell you
what happened and why it happened but I
can't figure out what's going to happen
I still I like villain over all year I
had them once I said got everything
they've got experience there
got relative size they're an excellent
three-point shooting team they're an
excellent defensive team they make
free-throws they don't turn the ball
over they have a great point guard they
have a great coach so yeah easily a
solid pick
I'm liking Duke the way they're playing
right now I had Bill Self did maybe the
best coaching job he's done but I like
Duke better just because of the pure
talent particularly up front I people
don't have anybody to deal with Bagley
and Grayson Allen's a great player so I
like Duke and Nova right now which means
unfortunately yes and Mike you can
probably eliminate both of them but well
they might have lip one of them might
eliminate the other if you're right you
know because that they would face each
other in the final forest PJ Carlesimo
here in the Rich Eisen show how often do
you think about 1989 if it's not brought
up to you up to me but I live in Seattle
right so I mean a week doesn't go by but
somebody doesn't say to me hey I was at
the game and he came down when you guys
got beat and funny we also played here
two years later though in the Elite
Eight we got beat by UNLV the undefeated
UN out of a team that might be - Duke
beat after doing LBD just you know
when's it in ninety we played him in 91
the team that was undefeated at that
time I don't know what they were thirty
you know or something like that in the
Elite Eight we we beat Arizona in the
round of 16 and we lose so you know -
pretty painful losses were in the
kingdom or you could say it was pretty
nice playing and championship game and
getting to the Elite Eight in the
kingdom so people bring it up you know
obviously you can't change it sometimes
you say you know damn we really we
should have won one but hey that's the
way it goes unfortunately at least they
blew the Kingdome up PJ's I hate some of
the domes and the one thing I don't like
we'll be in San Antonio obviously sure I
hate the big buildings you know it to me
I still would rather it be playing
played in a basketball building than
these football buildings but I
understand people want to beat I don't
know why you want to be there when
you're that far away from the action but
it is what it is I'm waiting
obviously it's it's big it's big money
big stuff I remember Rupp Arena held a
final for one year you know like oh I
couldn't barn right way back in the day
you know but if I guess that that 89
game at all I mean if you could change
one thing other than the result what
what what happened do you think that you
come wave Awards yeah honestly when it
was over we kids got a lot they gave him
great credit to Seton our kids for the
way they handle it they didn't
second-guess to call it you know we
talked to him and said hey it is what it
is don't you know take away from what
Michigan did I just wish obviously that
the call wasn't made because Remiel I
think remiel would have passed the ball
of alloy want they're coming down in
transition
Remiel could have shot it himself but I
think he probably throws the ball on the
right wing to Lloyd who was a good
shooter not a great shooter but a good
shooter and he makes it or misses it and
that's the way it should have ended but
it was one of those games where watching
the tape there wasn't a lot of things we
do differently truly we had the ball we
couldn't take it to the wire we had to
shoot it we missed our last shot we were
on the clock down and missed it and you
know we had a play we had worked on at
that morning at Seattle University
full-court pass but Terry Mills was on
Ramon Ramos and combination of Ramon was
on him the photographer's were behind
him he couldn't quite back up enough to
really make the kind of pass we wanted
so Darrell Walker did a good job
catching the ball but we didn't get the
shot we should have gotten out of that
even you know a full court situation it
was something we had worked on and
everyday and we finally got a chance to
use it it's funny we spent a lot of time
on it and obviously didn't execute it
very well when it when it mattered PJ
Carlesimo here on the Rich Eisen show
what did you think when you heard the
news that ty lue was stepping away for
what they're hoping is a short period of
time
right well I was very surprised I'm
actually flying to Cleveland and about
10 15 minutes but I've got Toronto at
Cleveland tomorrow night I was surprised
I didn't see that you know I had had
them a couple times I'm glad he did let
me say that I'm happy he did I'm hoping
that it's just what they said it is a
week away or something like that might
get him caught up I talked to Mike
fratello a real close friend who lives
in Cleveland and spends time with them
when he's not
we Turner and he he said that sleep is
the biggest issue I mean it you know
whatever is causing it he can't get to
sleep and I mean it's you don't get
enough sleep
when you're coaching in the NBA to begin
with when you I'm you know on top of
that when you got it's an issue getting
sleep you got no chance because you're
always tired to begin with because you
don't get enough sleep so he's got to
get that under control
I think Lu's done a great job rich to be
honest with you this stuff you know a
lot of people say yeah I like to coach
LeBron and ABCD but guess what
they've had issues every year it's been
like almost a circus in Cleveland every
year firing coaches and doing massive
trades in the middle of the year guys
leaving I mean it's amazing and I think
he's done a good job holding it together
holding it together getting to the
finals every year winning the
championship so I don't lose back just
knowing you know what it takes
PJ I mean what do you think goes on is
he staring up at the ceiling at 2:30 in
the morning I mean walk walk it uh
somebody threw all that I just think
it's so I don't know what I'm hoping
it's something that's caused by you know
some kind of medical thing that they can
get him some medicine and they can get
him something that gets a month in
control a little bit but he literally
cannot with what might fratellos
relating to me secondhand he can't fall
asleep well you think you just got no
chance I mean you know you're happy to
get 5/6 hours if you you know if it's
lucky a lot of nights and and getting
right here you lean on your assistants a
lot Larry Drew will do a great job right
now and but I mean there's just so much
whizzing in your head Chuck daily used
to have a number and I forget what it
was is to say how many decisions you
would make in an NBA game versus a
college game because it's you know
shorter time clock the end of the game
is so rigged up there with the clock
stopped and advancing the ball and
things like that that it's just you know
it's like constant decision so I can
understand it takes a while to wind down
but it can't take till 9 o'clock the
next morning you got no shot then I mean
just hope you'll have no energy left to
do the things you have to do last one
before you before you head off to the
airport PJ is our you know our poll
question today is asking fans if they're
superstitious when they watch a game
who's the most superstitious player or
coach you've ever been around oh damn I
should know that because I've been
around both you know what I
just because I'm approaching senility
rich I can't come up with it but I know
both I know coaches that wear same ties
same student game after game or big game
after big game MBA game after game but
big game after big game and coat there's
a lot of players that their routine is
identical and it's not necessarily
because you know it's a getting asleep
or getting the food it's crazy other
stuff that they do which route they take
to the gym and you know what what they
what they wear and stuff like that but I
I can't remember a name but there's a
lot there's a lot of it around believe
me and you never out of coaches that do
it there's a lot of players they never
worry yourself you never do no I think I
was always convinced it made no
difference I I was realistic to be
honest which I knew very little that I
was doing has a lot of impact on the
game so certainly what I was wearing or
what I was eating or what road I took to
the arena certainly wasn't going to
impact it PJ love our chat man let's
let's do it again real soon safe travels
I always enjoy listening to you I rich
you too Thank You Man appreciate he does
that now yeah you got it
yeah that's the rock PJ Carlesimo the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience